und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka abend
die vorwürfe gegen russland wegen
schwerer systematisches staatsdoping wie
zu zeiten des kalten krieges und
nachträglich systematisches vertuschen
die welt-anti-doping-agentur wada hat
daraufhin heute eine vierjährige sperre
gegen russland verhängt
auf den ersten blick scheint das ein
hartes urteil russland darf demnach
weder an den olympischen spielen
nächstes jahr in tokio noch 2022 in
peking teilnehmen und vermutlich auch
nicht bei der fußball wm in katar aber
und das ist ein großes aber wieder
bleibt ein hintertürchen offen durch das
russische sportler gehen können solange
sie keine russische fahne schwenken
andreas kribben berichtet auf dem papier
ist es erstmal eine strafe von
historischer härte für russland für
seine anhaltenden betrügereien im
dopingskandal heute vormittag die
verkündung der welt-anti-doping-agentur
wada in lausanne die konsequenzen
beinhalten die verbannung russlands von
olympischen spielen paralympics und
allen weltmeisterschaften für vier jahre
und ebenso das verbot solche
großveranstaltungen in diesem zeitraum
haus zu richten demnach darf russland
bei der kontinentalen fußball em 2020
staaten ist aber bei der wm 2022 in
katar nicht dabei bei den nächsten
beiden olympischen spielen und
paralympics können russische athleten
nur unter neutraler flagge staaten wie
schon in pyeongchang 2018
voraussetzung sie müssen sauber sein und
dürfen auch nicht im zusammenhang mit
manipulierten datensätzen auftauchen
die stammen aus dem moskauer kontroll
labor in dem mit hilfe eines staatlich
organisierten systems positive
dopingproben ausgetauscht und daten
verfälscht wurden
in dem labor wurden dopingproben
versteckt wurden also nicht der wahre
gemeldet und diese diese ergebnisse die
damals durchgeführt worden sind
insbesondere vom doktor chekov die haben
wir jetzt alle und deswegen können wir
auch alle ergebnisse entsprechend
bewerten
bei der ebenfalls gesperrten russischen
anti doping agentur usada gibt man sich
einsichtig unser problem besteht darin
dass bei uns nach wie vor veraltete
herangehensweisen angewendet werden die
unseren sport immer tiefer in der krise
versinken lassen
es ist wichtig die herangehensweise und
die leute auszutauschen
in russland wird ein dopingproblem
eingeräumt aber auch antirussische
history vermutet der sportminister
zweifelt die glaubwürdigkeit der
datenbank an auf deren basis das urteil
fußt
diese datenbank ist von einem
unbekannten erhalten worden auf ihrer
grundlage wurden die vorwürfe
vorgebracht können sie sich irgendeinen
straf oder zivildienst als maßstab
genommen wird ist unverständlich beim
verein athleten deutschland begrüßt man
das urteil fordert aber die prüfung ob
russische athletinnen und athleten unter
neutraler flagge an wettkämpfen
teilnehmen dürfen muss so transparent
nachvollziehbar und streng wie möglich
erfolgen
genau da sehen kritiker die gefahren des
auf den ersten blick harten urteils
angst vor schlupflöchern hintertürchen
und weiteren manipulationen vor allem
motiviert durch die angst vor dem
verlust von sponsorengeldern
russland hat einen einspruch angekündigt
dann muss der internationale
sportgerichtshof cas entscheiden auch
wenn am ende doch russische sportler den
bann umgehen werden für präsident putin
ist das war der urteil wohl dennoch eine
unangenehme begleitmusik zu seinem
auftritt heute in paris erstmals wieder
seit über drei jahren gibt es ein
gipfeltreffen zwischen russland
deutschland frankreich und der ukraine
um über den krieg in der ost ukraine zu
sprechen
pessimisten vermuten dass das auch schon
die einzige gute nachricht sein wird die
dazu verkündet werden kann immerhin man
spricht wieder miteinander
wer etwas optimistischer gesinnt ist
hofft zumindest auf die verabredung
einige alltags erleichterungen für die
betroffenen menschen in der region bevor
wir aktuell vom gipfeltreffen in paris
berichten fasst claudia voland noch mal
kurz zusammen worum es bei dem konflikt
geht
ende 2013 gehen in der ukraine
hunderttausende auf die straße sie
protestieren weil die ukrainische
regierung ein partnerschaftsabkommen mit
der eu abgesagt hat hintergrund ist die
frage ob die ukraine sich an die eu
ernährt oder an russland das land ist in
dieser frage tief gespalten
bis zum frühjahr 2014 eskaliert die lage
bei straßenkämpfen starben mehr als 100
menschen
moskau besetzt die ukrainische grimm und
gliedert die halbinsel in das russisches
staatsgebiet ein eu und usa verhängen
sanktionen gegen russland im osten der
ukraine demonstrieren zehntausende für
einen anschluss an russland separatisten
von moskau unterstützt kämpfen für die
abspaltung im sommer 2014 wird ein
flugzeug der american airlines über der
ukraine abgeschossen 298 menschen
sterben
laut eines internationalen
ermittlerteams war die ursache eine
russische flugabwehrraketen 2015 wird
auch unter deutscher vermittlung einen
friedensplan ausgehandelt der
waffenstillstand ist bis heute brüchig
2017 tritt das partnerschaftsabkommen
mit der eu in kraft
2009 10 gewinnt der bis dahin unbekannte
schauspieler selensky die
präsidentschaftswahl er möchte den krieg
beenden
nach un-angaben sind 3,5 millionen
ukrainer vor den kämpfen geflohen
an die 13.000 menschen sind gestorben ob
das noch jahre oder jahrzehnte so weiter
gehen wird hängt entscheidend von
russland ab wladimir putin hatte im
vorfeld des pariser gipfels auch
ziemlich deutlich gemacht dass er am
längeren hebel sitzt
zumal sein ukrainisches gegenüber ein
politik unerfahrener neuling ist
präsident selensky hatte im wahlkampf
versprochen bewegung in den
festgefahrenen konflikt zu bringen also
muss er jetzt auch liefern darf sich in
den augen seiner wähler aber auch nicht
über den tisch ziehen lassen
merkel und parkraum treten als
vermittler auf christel haus berichtet
aus paris
zwei leicht bekleideten aktivistinnen
direkt vor dem schwer bewachten
élysée-palast das hat schon
seltenheitswert
ein schnell weggeräumt protest gegen
kremlchef putin
doch der hat von alledem gar nichts
mitbekommen er stieg da gerade erst aus
dem flugzeug
dass dieses treffen stattfindet gilt
allein schon als erfolg frankreichs
präsident makro und kanzlerin merkel
sind entschlossen die beiden gegner in
der ukraine krise zu gegenseitigen
zugeständnissen zu bewegen
der neue ukrainische präsident selensky
gibt sich selbstbewusst
es ist das erste mal dass er und
russlands präsident putin sich
persönlich gegenüber sitzen
viel steht auf dem spiel es geht um
einen stabilen waffenstillstand um
truppenrückzug um einen sonderstatus für
die abtrünnigen regionen in der ost
ukraine und vor allem um die frage ob
putin bereit ist die ausgestreckte hand
anzunehmen
das bezweifeln viele in der ukrainischen
hauptstadt kiew tausende forderten
vergangenen nacht ihren noch
unerfahrenen präsidenten auf gegenüber
russland nicht einzuknicken
meine größte angst ist es dass er irgend
einen deal mit russland unterzeichnet
und dann unter putins fuchtel steht
ich befürchte dass es auf eine
kapitulation hinausläuft das darf nicht
passieren
ich will in einer ukraine leben die
geeint ist und stark im élysée ziehen
sich die verhandlungen hin
so führt zu zweit und ganz überraschend
treffen sich auch selensky und putin zu
einem vier augen gespräch
es heißt man verhandle über ein
abschlusspapier was drin steht bleibt
bislang aber noch geheim
die gemeinsame pressekonferenz hat immer
noch nicht begonnen
das für uns in paris was sie im moment
vom verlauf der gespräche
also wie vor diesem gipfel hier hatten
die delegation das intensiv vorbereitet
und hatten bereits auch eine
abschlusserklärung dort aufgeschrieben
verhandelt vorbereitet und darin sind
eine ganze reihe von punkten vorgesehen
die truppen entflechtungen in der
ukraine betreffen eine reihe von
humanitären maßnahmen betreffend neuen
gefangenenaustausch
und auch maßnahmen wie man den
waffenstillstand möglicherweise
dauerhaft sichern könne
mit diesem papier ist man in die
gespräche hinein gegangen und im lauf
des tages haben dann sowohl der élysée
als auch der kreml offiziell bestätigt
jawohl es wird an diesem papier
gearbeitet das deutet darauf hin dass
man hierzu irgendeine art von einigung
kommen wolle
ich habe am frühen abend einige der
daran beteiligten an diesen gesprächen
delegationsmitglieder gesehen und die
wirken da recht entspannt und meinten
sie hätten nichts gehört heute im lauf
des tages
was nun unvorhergesehen gewesen wäre und
wer etwa 20 minuten ging zufällig
wladimir putin an mir im élysée vorbei
den habe ich gefragt ob er denn mit dem
bis dahin erreichten
verhandlungsergebnis zufrieden sei und
er hat geantwortet ja er sei zufrieden
das muss jetzt noch nicht viel heißen
aber das bedeutet eben dass man
versuchen wir hier doch zu einer
einigung zu einem papier zu kommen
wie viel das dann im wirklichen leben
wird es das steht auf einem anderen
blatt denn auch die krise im deutsch
russischen verhältnis ein thema so
stichwort auftragsmorden einem berliner
park sie da sind deutsche diplomaten vor
diesen treffen hier auch nachgefragt
worden und die erwartung war dass
bundeskanzlerin merkel dieses thema in
ihrem bilateralen gespräch mit wladimir
putin wie es im beamtendeutsch heißt
ansprechen würde und die russische seite
auffordern würde doch einen beitrag zu
leisten zur aufklärung dieses falles
aber erkennbar war auch dass man nicht
wollte dass dieser konflikt diesem
gipfel hier überschatten würde das
sollte unabhängig geschehen von den
verhandlungen um die ukraine
und ganz ähnlich war es auch bei den
franzosen auch diesen gefragt worden
nach diesem fall dort in berlin und die
haben geantwortet man kenne den fall man
verstehe die deutsche reaktion darauf
und man zeige sich solidarisch mit
deutschland aber mehr sagte man dann
eben nicht was dass wir diesen gipfel
bedeuten könne
auch da war ganz offensichtlich die
marschrichtung man will nicht dass
dieses treffen von diesen konflikt oder
von vielen anderen die man derzeit mit
russland hat noch weiter überschattet
und danke steht thomas informationen aus
paris und jetzt erstmal die nachrichten
in washington treiben die demokraten im
repräsentantenhaus ihre bemühungen um
ein amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen
präsident ramp voran
während einer anhörung im
justizausschuss lieferten sich
abgeordnete beider seiten hitzige
wortgefechte und am ende dieser
entscheidenden sitzungen müssen die
abgeordneten die vorwürfe gegen trump zu
einzelnen anklagepunkten ausformulieren
das repräsentantenhaus entscheidet dann
ob das verfahren eröffnet und an den
senat weitergeleitet wird die zweite
kammer im parlament wie das verfahren
führen muss interessante zahlen des
stockholmer friedensforschungsinstituts
sipri seit 2002 untersuchen dessen
experten die verkäufe der 100 größten
rüstungskonzerne weltweit und die sind
bis ende vergangenen jahres um knapp 47
prozent gestiegen
allein 2008 10 wurden rüstungsgüter im
wert von 380 milliarden euro verkauft
ein anstieg von 4,6 prozent im vergleich
zum vorjahr
an erster stelle stehen die usa
deutschland steht an neunter stelle mit
etwa 75 milliarden euro
china wurde wegen fehlender daten nicht
erfasst
in frankreich gingen die proteste gegen
die angekündigte rentenreform der
regierung heute bereits in den fünften
tag erneut wurden die pariser metro und
vorstadt züge teilweise bestreikt
entsprechend voll war es auf den straßen
vor allem im morgendlichen berufsverkehr
morgen soll es weitere proteste geben am
mittwoch will die regierung dann
einzelheiten ihrer renten pläne
bekanntgeben
die eu kommission hat grünes licht
gegeben für die förderung der
sogenannten batterien allianz in sieben
ländern darunter deutschland
europa hinkt bei der fertigung von
batteriezellen für elektroautos bislang
hinterher
das soll sich ändern nun dürfen
insgesamt zuschüsse von bis zu 3,2
milliarden euro fließen etwa für die
entwicklung neuer batterien module und
recycling verfahren
im fall des getöteten feuerwehrmann es
in augsburg ist gegen alle sieben
verdächtigen haftbefehl erlassen worden
dem mutmaßlichen haupttäter einem 17
jährigen wird totschlag und gefährliche
körperverletzung vorgeworfen den sechs
anderen beihilfe und gemeinschaftliche
körperverletzung
die attacke auf den 49 jährigen dauerte
laut ermittlern nur wenige sekunden das
opfer sei unvermittelt von der seite und
mit voller wucht gegen den kopf
geschlagen worden was zum tod geführt
habe warum die gruppe auf ihn und einen
weiteren mann losging ist nicht bekannt
als nach der wahl der beiden neuen spd
chefs von allen sozialdemokratischen
seiten zu neuer geschlossenheit
aufgerufen wurde ahnte man schon das
wird schwierig vor allem das
zusammenspiel mit der spd fraktion so
richtig lustig fanden die genossen im
parlament ist nämlich nicht wie das
siegerduo ihre koalitionsarbeit schlecht
gemacht hatte vor allem saskia esken war
da als gruppe kritikerin ziemlich robust
aufgetreten und legte inzwischen noch
mal nach indem sie öffentlich klar
machte dass für die nun anstehenden
verhandlungen mit der union die
parteispitze also sie und co chef walter
borjans zuständig sein
das dürfte bei den fraktionskollegen
nicht so gut angekommen sein
irritationen gibt es aber auch beim
koalitionspartner die union wüsste gern
mit wem sie denn nun künftig gespräche
führt muss sich aber auch selbst noch
sortieren aus berlin florian a
sie sind misstrauisch geworden in der
union man merkt das an ihrer reaktion
auf eine frage drei cdu-politiker
dreimal fast dieselbe art auszuweichen
was würden sie wetten ist die große
koalition auch im nächsten jahr zur
selben zeit im amt ich wette nur ungern
und wenn du im sport naja
regierungsbildung sind kein spiel und
sind auch keinen kein kasino animation
ob man wettet oder nicht wettert ich
werde nicht es rechtlich so was dass die
neue spd-spitze themen wie klimaschutz
oder schwarze null nachverhandeln will
diese nachricht ist heute ein paar tage
alt genauso alt ist die zumindest
vordergründig geeinte antwort der union
darauf gibt es nicht
auch heute geäußert vor jeder kamera es
wird keine nachverhandlungen dieses
koalitionsvertrages geben dieser
koalitionsvertrag steht fest und schon
gar nicht wird es eine rütteln an der
schwarzen null oder gar an der
schuldenbremse geben
das klingt nach klarer kante doch wer
nachfragt wird unterschiede in der
tonlage hier etwa zwei
ministerpräsidenten beide mit ambitionen
beide gegen nachverhandlungen der eine
aber nimmt worte wie konstruktiv in den
mund der andere sieht die stabilität des
landes in gefahr
der parteitag der spd ist ein einschnitt
nach dem spd parteitag hat sich die
politische stabilität in deutschland
verändert regieren wird schwieriger das
wird sich jetzt mal zeigen
die neue führung muss da es erst mal die
chance haben sich zu ordnen und ich
finde dass wir von uns aus dass
konstruktiv begleiten sollten und dann
ist da noch ein dritter ebenfalls in
lauerstellung der nebenbei mal wieder
eine unionsgeführte minderheitsregierung
ins spiel bringt es wird schwierig
werden sagt friedrich merz mit einer spd
weiter zu regieren
das muss auch ohne diese elf prozent
partei gehen
erst mal aber wie man sich treffen in
der groko koalitionsausschuss mit den
neuen spd chefs voraussichtlich nächste
woche
die terminfindung läuft noch
übers klima wird derweil hier im
bundesrat heute abend schon verhandelt
vermittlungsausschuss zum klimapaket es
geht um die verteilung der steuern oder
wird der von der groko bereits
beschlossene co2 preis doch noch
angetastet
wer vermittlungsverfahren kennt weiß
dass die thematik immer breiter angelegt
es ein geschlossenes paket von bundestag
und bundesrat neu aufzumachen das geht
gar nicht
die groko und die neue spd spitze wird
es einem der partner bald zu bunt
der neue anstrich des willy brandt
hauses hat damit nichts zu tun
nach den tätern fahndet der staatsschutz
die arbeit in der parteizentrale seien
nicht beeinträchtigt gewesen sagte ein
sprecher der partei heute immerhin nach
dem vulkanausbruch in neuseeland dürfte
sich die zahl der todesopfer noch
erhöhen
bislang wurden fünf tote gemeldet doch
weitere acht menschen werden noch
vermisst
und die neuseeländische polizei rechnet
nicht mehr damit noch überlebende zu
finden
viele opfer sind ausländische touristen
unter den verletzten könnten auch
deutsche seien
sie besichtigten die unbewohnte insel
als der vulkanausbruch auf island liegt
rund 50 kilometer vor der küste der
nordinsel neuseelands und ist eine
bekannte touristenattraktion die gerne
von kreuzfahrtschiffen angesteuert wird
normen odenthal berichtet 50 kilometer
vom festland entfernt aber nicht zu
übersehen die aschewolke des vaccari
neuseelands aktivster vulkan trotzdem
kommt die eruption für die touristen
völlig unerwartet plötzlich und mit
enormer kraft einige wandern war gerade
am rande des kraters von einem
augenblick auf den anderen sind die
urlauber in lebensgefahr weg vom vulkan
weg von der insel das schaffen nicht
mehr alle rechtzeitig es gibt tote und
verletzte
wir können noch immer nicht genau sagen
wie viele menschen vom ausbruch
betroffen sind wir versuchen aktuell so
schnell und effizient wie möglich die
exakten zahlen zu bekommen
vor allem ist unklar wie viele menschen
noch immer auf der insel sind
verletzte sind aufs festland geflogen
wurden mit brandwunden aber in
sicherheit die rettungsflüge mussten
bald eingestellt werden der auch die
asche machten den einsatz zu gefährlich
sagt die polizei und der jetzt noch
nicht gefunden wurde habe
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht überlebt die
lage ist instabil sagen uns die geologen
es besteht die möglichkeit weitere
eruptionen im moment ist für die
rettungskräfte eine rückkehr auf die
insel deshalb zu riskant forscher sollen
kürzlich erhöhte aktivität des vulkans
gemessen haben warum die touristen die
insel dennoch besuchen durften gehört zu
den fragen die es zu klären gilt
1 wolf macht weiter hat zunächst die
deutschen exporte sind im oktober im
schnitt um 1,9 prozent gegenüber dem
oktober letzten jahres gestiegen
das hat das statistische bundesamt
bekannt gegeben in einer zeit von
rezessionsängsten sind das ja immerhin
pluszeichen frank bethmann da ist wie
ist die weitere einschätzung ja eine
willkommene abwechslung sei da sagte
vorhinein chefvolkswirt einer der großen
banken hier
man hatte mit weniger gerechnet aber
optimismus wollte dennoch nicht
aufkommen
mit blick auf die dürre in den
auftragsbüchern gibt es dafür überhaupt
keinen grund
umso überraschender war
hauptverantwortlich dafür dass große
ausfuhrvolumen ausgerechnet möchte man
fast sagen die usa wichtigster abnehmer
von deutschen waren aber auch größter
störfaktor für den welthandel sehr viel
besser liefen die geschäfte im oktober
auch mit frankreich saudi arabien und
den vereinigten arabischen emiraten
nichtsdestotrotz die deutschen
exporteure bezeichnen 2009/10 schon
jetzt als gebrauchtes jahr unterm strich
steht da bislang nur ein mäßiges
wachstum von 1 prozent im kommenden
droht sogar ein rückgang bei den
ausfuhren
das rezessions gespenst also längst
nicht vertrieben schaute heute auch kurz
beim dax vorbei am ende ein minus von
einem halben prozent doch was ist das
verglichen mit dem handel seit
jahresbeginn plus 24 prozent konnte das
aktienbarometer seit januar zulegen was
für ein krasser gegensatz hier vor allem
die industrie mit großen sorgenfalten
dort die in der
dohren mit breiter brust das schlimmste
in sachen konjunktur sei überstanden
heißt es heute dazu passend in einer
monatlichen umfrage unter anlegern
mal schauen wer später recht hat frank
bethmann
vielen dank die deutschen
handballerinnen haben bei der wm in
japan ihr zweites hauptrundenspiel gegen
serbien mit 28 29 verloren
damit haben sie den vorzeitigen einzug
ins halbfinale und die olympia
qualifikation verpasst nun fällt die
entscheidung erst am mittwoch im spiel
gegen rekord europameister norwegen
der berliner zoo hat heute die namen
seiner kleinen panda zwillinge verkündet
meint jung und männlich höher angesetzt
ersehnter traum und erfüllter traum die
namen dürfen nach der chinesischen
tradition erst 100 tage nach der geburt
verraten werden
bis besucher den nachwuchs live sehen
können dauert es noch ein paar wochen
der hollywood blockbuster black panther
ist in den usa einer der umsatzstärksten
filme aller zeiten
dabei hatten verleihen vorfeld sorge
dass ein film mit fast ausschließlich
afroamerikanischer besetzung ist beim
weißen publikum schwer haben würde
abgesehen davon dass diese frage in
hollywood umgekehrt offenbar nicht
gestellt wird erwies sich das als
grandiose fehleinschätzung auch in
deutschland zogen lag panzer ein
millionenpublikum in die kinos bei der
verfilmung von crazy richey sions gab es
ähnliche bedenken
die buchreihe über ihre reiche asiaten
deren lebenswirklichkeit in der tat
crazy ist wasser bereits ein bestseller
aber sollte man wirklich ausschließlich
asiatische darsteller auf die leinwand
lassen
am ende war auch dieser film weltweit
ein riesenerfolg
nicht aber in deutschland da wurde
nämlich kaum gezeigt und die bücher sind
sogar erst in diesem jahr auf deutsch
erschien
claudia muster berichtet
der plot ist schnell erzählt eine junge
asiatische frau aus new york verliebt
sich in einen jungen asiatischen man
doch seine sehr reiche familie in
singapur ist gegen sie
sie ist zu arm das war's eine tragische
liebesgeschichte diese hübschen bilder
sind übrigens der trailer zum buch
wichtiger ist crazy rich agence
beschreibt die familien die über die
geschicke des fernen ostens bestimmen
das macht dieses buch so interessant der
autor kevin quoren stammt selbst aus
einer reichen singapur familie
wir treffen ihn in beverly hills ein
super exklusives asiatisches restaurant
begrüßung vom chef persönlich und
eintritt nur mit fingerabdruck wenn es
denn funktioniert korn verwendet im buch
nicht den begriff superreich sondern
china china reich ist ein ganz anderes
level diese leute haben keinen privatjet
sondern eine privat jet flotte zehn oder
zwanzig familien gehören alle banken und
unternehmen
und sie haben sehr großen einfluss auf
die politik
das buch wurde ein megaseller
millionenfach verkauft den usa und china
und aus dem buch erfolg wurde ein kino
blockbuster ein wichtiger hollywood
wollte als hauptfigur keine asiatin
sondern eine weiße amerikaner ich sagte
zu ihm du hast gar nichts verstanden und
nein danke jetzt haben wir den ersten
hollywood film mit nur asiatischen
darstellern seit 25 jahren und es wurde
die erfolgreichste romantische komödie
der letzten zehn jahre
nur eben nicht in deutschland
deutschland war besorgt ein film mit
ausschließlich asiatischen schauspielern
und dann auch noch den wort agence im
titel lieber nicht
der deutsche filmverleih spricht das
wort agence einer frau diese sorge ob
die geschichte auch über die grenzen
hinweg funktionieren kann ich fand das
beleidigend diese geschichte versteht
jeder warum sollten die leute sie nicht
liegen so wie harry potter oder star
wars
das sind große vergleiche etwas zu groß
aber der erfolg spricht für kevin kline
in china und usa ist eine celebrity wird
auf der straße erkannt und so weiter
seine familie in singapur nennt ihn
übrigens banane in weiß amerikanisiert
verwestlicht jetzt mit etwas verspätung
gibt es seine sozialstudien des hyper
reichtums auch auf deutsch die crazy
rich agence trilogie geschichten über
die wahren machthaber in fernost
verpackt als love story das las torres
kulturübergreifend funktionieren sollte
ja eigentlich auch keine neue erkenntnis
sein
gleich geht's erstmal grenzübergreifend
weiter mit der krimireihe der pass und
danach um 05 gibt es heute plus mit
daniel bröckerhoff bis morgen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
genome liebe zuschauer in den
mittelgebirgen in den alpen oder an den
alpen gibt es jetzt wieder schnee das
wird ja etwas kühler die temperaturen
morgen mit europa erreichen nur so werte
um 5 grad dauerfrost haben wir vor allem
in skandinavien mit null bis minus zehn
grad und am mittelmeer erleben wir immer
noch einigermaßen mildes oder warmes
wetter mit 15 zum teil eben immer noch
20 grad bei uns geht's nach zäher runter
wieder in den frostbereich nur leichter
frost zwischen null und minus zwei grad
verbreitet an den küsten bleibt es
frostfrei
aber es wird sehr glatt zum teil wenn es
dann überfriert denn wir erwarten ja
noch weitere schnee und regen schauer
die so langsam nach südosten ziehen
dauerschneefall gibt es dann in der
nacht an den alpen in den mittelgebirgen
wird es auch anfangen zu schneien und
kurzzeitig kann der wind noch mal
kräftig werden dann mehr im osten und im
süden stürmische böen erwarten wir dort
und wie gesagt glätte auf jeden fall in
der nacht auf morgen glätte noch vor
allem südlich der donau
da schneit es noch weiter sonst gibt es
schneeschauer am erzgebirge aber meist
beginnt der tag doch freundlich im
norden mit sonne und wolken genauso wie
im westen nachmittags lässt der
schneefall dann an den alpen endlich
nach dafür wird hier oben im nordwesten
und im westen bewirkt der wind frischt
auf es gibt erste stürmische böen an der
nordsee am späten nachmittag die
temperaturen erreichen dann meist so
zwischen 5 und 7 grad aber in bayern
mittelgebirgen nur so 0 bis 4 grad ja
der mittwoch bringt uns neue sturm neuen
regen schnee wahrscheinlich auch im
sauerland donnerstag wird es ein
bisschen ruhiger und freitag geht es
schon wieder weiter mit sturm mit schnee
und regen ihnen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut